- [Instructor] Hey there, friends.
Today, we're gonna learn
about air pollution.
And to start off, we're going back in time
to the small town of Donora, Pennsylvania,
in October of 1948.
(pensive harp music)
Walking into this small industrial town,
you can immediately sense
that something is wrong.
It's the middle of the day,
but there's a thick
yellowish smog everywhere,
enveloping everything and
even blocking out the sun.
It's so dark that streetlights
are on during the daytime.
It stings your eyes and it's
hard, even painful to breathe.
What we're experiencing
is the Donora Death Fog,
one of the worst air pollution disasters
in the United States.
Donora was an industrial town
full of steel plants and mills
which released toxic emissions,
such as hydrogen fluoride
and sulfur dioxide
when processing steel and other metals.
Normally, these poisonous gases
would disperse into the atmosphere.
But this time, there was
a temperature inversion,
which caused a blanket of warm air
to cover a layer of colder
air near the surface
and ride over Donora.
Consequently, the toxic emissions
were essentially trapped
under the warm air.
Over the course of several days
from October 26th to October 31st,
these toxic emissions
had accumulated so much
that half of the 14,000
people living in Donora
suffered from respiratory
problems and 20 people died.
Relief only came when the
steel mills were shut down
and a rainstorm alleviated the smog.
But following the deadly Donora smog,
the public began to
realize just how dangerous
and life-threatening
air pollution could be,
and citizens demanded change.
Donora became a turning
point in US history
and was a start of the clean air movement.
The Air Pollution Control Act of 1955
was the first piece of
US federal legislation
involving air pollution and provided funds
for research about air pollution.
Then, in 1963, the Clean
Air Act was passed,
the first federal legislation
to control air pollution,
and later expanded in 1970,
which resulted in the creation
of the US Environmental
Protection Agency, the EPA,
to develop and enforce regulations
to protect the general public
from exposure to major
outdoor air pollutants.
The Clean Air Act was expanded
in 1977 and again in 1990.
And throughout its nearly-60-year history,
our air quality has drastically improved
and pollutants have dropped sharply.
Since 1990, major air pollutants
such as carbon monoxide,
nitrogen oxides, sulfur dioxide,
and volatile organic compounds
have greatly decreased,
and that's just since 1990.
These four main air
pollutants that I highlighted
are largely released as emissions
from burning fossil fuels,
which comes from driving vehicles
and operating coal-fired power plants
and other industrial facilities.
So, as we've started to
drive more efficient vehicles
and obtain more energy from
clean renewable sources,
we've decreased the amount
of fossil fuels that we use.
And in turn, we've reduced emissions
from fossil fuels and
associated air pollutants.
But how does the Clean
Air Act work exactly?
How do we clean the air
and limit emissions of harmful pollutants?
Clean Air Act regulations
implemented by the EPA
have led to new technologies
that help to limit emissions
and remove pollutants from the air.
In particular, many of these technologies
help to reduce air pollution
from coal-burning power
plants and vehicles.
Each of these
pollution-control technologies
functions to remove harmful
components out of emissions
and release a less harmful substance.
In the last decade or so,
you've also probably noticed
more and more electric
vehicles on the road.
Improving the fuel economy of vehicles
and even using battery-powered
electric vehicles
can reduce the need to
burn as much gasoline,
thereby reducing emissions
and giving us cleaner air.
A good example is the growing demand
for hybrid and purely electric vehicles.
Here we have a simplified figure
that explains the sources of energy
for different types of vehicles
and their respective emissions.
On the left, we have
conventional vehicles,
which rely on fossil fuels
such as gasoline or diesel
and, when driven,
produce lots of emissions
like carbon dioxide and air pollutants.
Hybrid and plug-in hybrid vehicles
are similar to conventional vehicles
in that they have an
internal combustion engine,
but they also have an electric motor
which uses energy stored in batteries.
These batteries can be charged
by regenerative braking
or, in the case of plug-in hybrids,
just by using a wall outlet
or other charging equipment.
In turn, because these hybrid cars
are partially fueled by batteries,
they produce fewer emissions
than a conventional car.
Finally, vehicles that
rely solely on electricity,
known as battery electric
vehicles or BEVs,
can use an alternative electricity source
so that there's no emissions
at the source of the electricity.
What else can we do to ensure cleaner air?
We can reduce our reliance on fossil fuels
and instead invest in
cleaner renewable resources
to generate electricity such
as geothermal, wind, and solar.
And we can make decisions
in our day-to-day lives
to reduce or prevent air pollution
by using less energy
and alternative fuels.
For example, walking, biking,
or using mass transportation
can reduce the need to burn fossil fuels.
And there are plenty of other ways
to reduce our electrical needs;
in particular, using more
energy-efficient appliances.
For example, think of the LED bulb,
which uses 75% less energy
than incandescent lighting.
So, even switching out bulbs
in the lights around
your house or apartment
can make a huge difference.
But there's still many other
places out there like Donora,
and oftentimes folks living in cities
with heavy air pollution
literally can't afford to leave.
There's still much work to be done.
In Donora, though, there's
the Donora Smog Museum,
which has the tagline
"Clean air started here."
The terrible incident
suffered by Donora's community
played a huge and pivotal role
in opening the eyes of Americans
to the hazards of air pollution
and spurred political action
that's carried forth through today
and will continue into the future.
Let's all take a deep breath
and be glad that we can.